When I was 17, I made $6 an hour. When I
was 21, I got to $25 an hour. When I was
23, I got to $250 an hour. When I was
26, I got to $2,500 per hour. When I was
28, I got to $18,000 an hour. And so, in
this video, I'll show you three ways to
10x your income. So, the first way is
through something called arbitrage. And
so, arbitrage is just a fancy word uh
that means buying and selling between
two different markets and capitalizing
on the difference in price for the same
asset. Now, there's a lot of ways that
you can arbitrage. So this applies for
both businesses and employees. Entire
financial sector is almost built on
arbitrage which is can I buy a stock uh
for a certain price and then sell it
later. And that's where you have options
trading and all these other types of
things um that banks and financial
institutions will make hundreds of
billions of dollars a year on. So,
number one, on a personal level, you can
uh buy cheap locally wherever you're at,
and then sell whatever you have, like
your services even to a more expensive
market, which is why the number one
money-making skill in 2024 is English.
And so if you live in a foreign country
and you live in Thailand or you live in
Malaysia, you live in Vietnam, whatever,
you have something where it's very cheap
to live and then you can sell your
services globally at the most expensive
market rate, which would be probably
Europe and the US, then you could in a
real way have this big arbitrage between
what you make and what you spend. And
so, for example, in Thailand, the median
income is about $2,700 per year. And so
if you can sell your services even at
the US median income, which is closer to
like 50 or $60,000, you're looking at
more than a 10x increase between what
you make and what you spend. And wealth,
which a lot of people don't understand,
wealth is a ratio. It's not a number.
It's the it's how much you spend
relative to how much you make. So you
can make $50,000 a month or $500,000 a
month. If you spend more than that,
you're going to feel poor. Now, if you
make $5,000 a month and you spend 500,
you're going to feel rich because you
always have more than enough. And the
key about wealth is having more than you
need. And so, you can either make more
or need less. So, let me show you this
to you visually. So, personally, right,
you have a couple options. So, one is
your income stays the
same, but you decrease your expenses by
moving geographies. So, you change where
you live. The other way is that you can
live somewhere that's normal. It depends
on where you're starting, right? And
then
sell to a different geography overall.
Now, again, there's an interesting story
that I'll tell you. When I had my really
nice mansion in um Austin, this is years
ago. Um I noticed that when people came
to my house to bid services, I was like,
I feel like this is way more expensive
than a comparable service that I've paid
for in the past. And then I started
talking to my neighbors about it and
they're like, "Oh, that's just called
the zip code tax." And I was like, "What
does that mean?" They're like, "You have
a nice house. People will just raise the
prices because they know you can afford
it." And I was like, "Oh, well that
sucks." Um, and so I learned about that.
Um, now I'll tell you a real example of
a company that I actually invested in.
So, um, I live in a high-rise building
now, and there was a guy who met me in
the elevator and he literally elevator
pitched me for his business idea. And I
thought the business idea was actually
really interesting and he had a
prototype. He pulled it up on his phone
literally. I mean it's I live high up so
there's a decent amount of time in the
elevator and um I ended up going to
dinner with him and I ended up investing
in the business and it's actually one of
our portfolio companies and so uh I
asked him though because I knew what the
revenue of the business was. I was like
how can you afford to live here? And he
said I can't afford not to live here
because I get to meet people like you.
And so he was way living above his
means, but the arbitrage that he was
basically getting into was network
arbitrage is that he was basically
overpaying to have access to the best,
you know, the people who had the most
money in that specific market. And I
still am not the biggest fan of that
because it's so risky. But he ended up
funding his entire growth of the
software company um based on people that
he met in our building. And so I find
that kind of interesting. and he ended
up proving it out and the company's
actually really successful. So, it's
definitely one of those like I wouldn't
do it this way, but people have done it
and it obviously worked. And so, these
personal income things I still think
completely apply to business because the
only way you can go aggressive in
business is being able to reinvest
capital as you grow. And if you're just
making income, the amount of capital
that you have to get aggressive with is
proportional to uh what you make versus
what you spend. And so, it's like if you
don't know how to make more, just spend
way less. like when I uh started that
the my first gym, I was first living on
the floor. But even before that, when I
made the transition, when I wasn't sure
where I was going to have the gym, I
lived in a spare bedroom for $400 a
month. And so, like, I I I bring this up
because it's not like I was balling out.
And mind you, I had money saved up. I
had $50,000 saved up and I was making at
the time about $4,000 a month um from
training people online before I made my
transition to my gym. And so I I say
this to say like I strongly encourage
you to employ some level of arbitrage
within your life either in your business
or personally or both. And you can do
that geographically. You can do it via
network. Or you can just do it by
massively decreasing your spend by
spreading your expenses between more
people which is how I just just shared a
bedroom uh with somebody and only bought
food from Costco and that was the only
food that I ate. And so at the most
basic level, all business actually comes
down to some sort of arbitrage because
even if you have a skill difference from
someone else, you have an information
advantage. And so the arbitrage you have
is that it c you know how to do
something for less than it costs someone
else to do it. And so they pay you to do
that thing. And the arbitrage between
what it cost you and what you charge
them is how you make a profit. And so
arbitrage is absolutely at the core of
everything economic where basically
profit is created. The best part about
arbitrage is that you can employ it at
all levels of personal income. So even
if you're just working a job versus you
make a ton of money uh in your business.
There are levels of it and I would
encourage you to start when you have
nothing because you basically arbitrage
is a way of thinking. It's like how will
I live my life in a way that I always
have this this differential between what
something costs me and what I can sell
it for in the future. So, the second way
that you can 10x your income is through
increasing the number of people who know
who you are. Now, the way to do that is
to give away amazing stuff for free. All
right? And so, giveaways is one of the
strongest uh I mean, they're so strong
that they're literally regulated by the
government. That's a really good
telltale sign that something works is
that the government steps in because
it's so powerful that people abuse it.
And so, the two most powerful words in
marketing are free and new. And so when
you have a new giveaway, you want to
have it be something free. Now, I have
been able to 10x my income multiple
times in my life, like I said earlier.
Um, and I have done it basically in
every business through some sort of
giveaway. And I'll explain what that is.
So, the first massive increase when I
talked about um was actually through
something that we called the six week
challenge. All right? Which was where we
actually just gave away uh six weeks of
service and accountability and workouts
and nutrition planning and everything to
people. Now, no one else in my market
could compete against that because they
were just giving trials, 14 days,
sometimes 21 days, and it was just like
workouts or it was just access to the
gym. I gave away a full program. Now, I
had a way of structuring it so that they
would pay, but then they'd get the money
back if they did it, and that encouraged
people to uh to give it a shot. But, it
was it was what took the gym to a
completely different stratosphere. And
just trying to do traditional marketing
just didn't really work that well, or at
least I got traditional results, which
were mediocre. Now the next uh big thing
that I did was uh in gym launch I wrote
the gym launch secrets book. And you'll
notice this is a common theme for me uh
is that I write books before I get into
any market. And I do that for a couple
reasons. One is that when I write a book
before I get into a market, the writing
process itself is actually a learning
process for me. And so it's like how
much can I learn? How much can I
consolidate um and synthesize
information uh to put it into a really
coherent way because I think writing is
one of the best ways of learning how to
think. And so the gym launch secrets
book, the reason this was so crazy is
that it outlines everything that we did
to turn around gyms. And I was so afraid
to publish this because I was like, "Oh
my god, it's going to be all my secrets.
Everyone's going to have it." But then
this is where a lot of the give away the
secrets, sell the implementation mindset
came from. And so you should never be
afraid of the things that you're giving
away. And this this process of doing
these types of giveaways is what
generates huge amounts of demand. And so
fundamentally, if you're going to grow a
business, you either got to get way more
customers if it would 10x. It's like we
got to 10x the customers. We got to 10x
how much they're worth. And I'll get to
that later. So, I'm going to put
something to rest that you're probably
worried about. I was so frightened to
launch Gym Launch Secrets, the book,
because it was like this is everything
that I learned. I was like, "This is
like my life's work." Um, in this book,
it's 400 pages of how to just run a gym.
Like, it's it's everything. It's like
the trainer ads, the the salesman ads,
the training, the scripts, how to set up
your lobby, like the the the the upsell
process, the different pricing packages,
how to do semi-private, how to do
larger, like everything was in there.
And I will say this, like at a lot of
big decision points in my life, like Ila
kind of like put her hand on my shoulder
and she's like, "If you're afraid that
it's too good, it's probably the right
thing to give away." And I remember
being like, "All right, like like here
goes nothing, you know, like this could
destroy us." But the thing that ended up
happening is two things. One is that all
my sales team was like, "Can you give
away more books?" Anybody who's read the
book is like so bought into our method,
our way of doing things. like they
immediately like we don't have to sell
them on the gym launch way. They just
like they're like can we just I just
need your help. I want to do it right. I
want to do it right the first time. I
don't want to try and like trial and
error this thing which was the goal. But
the sales guy saying that I was like
okay well that's super encouraging. And
the second thing I'll tell you later but
this one is one of the most effective
ways and I'll give a couple more
examples. So when I uh started my
software company Allen what I did was I
gave away and this is crazy. I gave away
basically unlimited coaching and uh
training like a whole course that most
people would charge a gazillion dollars
for. I just gave it away for anybody who
used my software. And so with Allen, we
were able to go from zero to $1.7
million per month. All right, just using
this within six months. And so most
people were trying to charge agency
owners like show them how to sell
customers, how to how to package their
offers, how to run ads. I did all of
that for free for anyone who just used
my software. And so that was like a
crazy offer. That was a crazy giveaway.
And that's what generated a ton of
demand inbound for Prestige Labs, which
was my supplement company. The big thing
that I gave away there was the entire
what I called supplement selling
secrets. I I used to say secrets a lot.
I don't say it anymore. Um, but I had I
I eventually called it S3, which was the
selling system uh for supplements. And
so this is something that had made me I
mean so much money in my gym career that
it took me two years to release it
because I was like I held it so close to
my chest. Hey, if you actually want to
implement this in your business, just
send this video to whoever is going to
be implementing it or your partner or
just to yourself if you need to or share
it to your story. It would mean the
world to me. Otherwise, back to the
video. But basically, instead of selling
this, I just gave it away and then I
just encouraged people to sell my
product. Now the thing is is that people
could take this and many people did.
They just took the selling system and
then just sold other supplements. But I
had built prestige to have specific
technical components into how the
business was operated that made it it
made it so much more advantageous for
people who went through this training to
use my supplements. So it's like I
showed people how to sell massive
bundles, how to sell subscriptions, all
of these things. And I priced it so that
anybody who would sell would be able to
have a discount far below what someone
could get for retail. And so it was
specifically made for people who were
going to go through this free giveaway.
And you're like, man, did he stop there?
No. Because with school, like right now,
for example, we're giving a $100,000
away uh or a cyber truck to the person
who uses the software, right, and gets
um and builds the biggest group uh
within a 30-day period. And we've done
uh three of these so far, and I think
we're doing another one here in
December. But the thing here is that
this is what generates a ton of demand
on the front end. And so, it's like if
you want to if you want to 10x, you
can't do an incremental change. you have
to do an order of magnitude difference.
And so that comes from giving away
actual tangible value, real stuff. Like
people were charging $10,000, $20,000
for what I was giving away here for
free. Um, and the thing is it's not
like, oh, I just like just like tossed
it up. I actually had the support the
same way somebody who ran a business
that had like a coaching business would
run it, except I just did it for free.
And with Prestige Labs, same thing. We
had reps who would go out, call the gym
owners up, train their teams on how to
sell the product. All stuff that you'd
normally charge for, we did for free.
Um, gym launch secrets, six week
challenge, the $100,000, like all of
these things had real costs that we were
willing to incur because it generated so
much more demand that it was offset with
the amount of customers that we could
bring in the door. And the only way that
you can do a giveaway longterm is that
you have to have some sort of product
that you know you're going to sell in
the back end. Like you have to still
have a monetization system that makes
sense. like it still has to lead to uh
something. So like here it's like cool
this led to the memberships, right? And
then gym launch secret led to gym launch
which was the licensing, right? And then
Allan led to the software. Prestige Labs
led to the products. And so each of them
basically I gave away this thing that
was really valuable. But then it led to
we monetized a different way, which I've
said this before, but my favorite
business model in the entire world is
look at what everyone else is buying,
make it better, make it free, monetize
another way. And so even with uh
acquisition.com I wrote both the books
uh that are free and I just just
recently released the scaling roadmap uh
which you know most people charge a
gazillion dollars for. It's 14 hours uh
and every single stage has 30-ish pages
of what you need to do uh to solve the
problems to get to the next level. And
it's free. You can just go get it. It's
on the site. But the whole point here is
that this is what this allows you to
provide outsized value to people. And
it's I I bring this up and I show each
of these examples, right? because people
don't believe me or at least they I see
the giveaways people do and they're just
lame. They either don't do it because
they're afraid of giving too much value
away or they give away something that
just doesn't have a lot of value. But
you the the key is that there has to be
some sort of hard cost that people can
actually realize like oh this is real
value that I'm getting for free because
otherwise you don't have reciprocity. We
want to jam value into someone else's
wallet so that they then have to
transfer it back to us in the form of
money later. Now the big key here is
that you got to be willing to wait. But
if you can do that, the cool thing is is
that so few people have that level of
discipline. This strategy will literally
always be available. I can shout it from
the rooftops and still 95% of you aren't
going to do it. And so if you're like,
how do I come up with this thing that I
give away for free um in$und00 million
leads, I wrote a whole chapter on this,
engage your leads uh with offers and
lead magnets. And I basically break down
exactly what you need to do and how to
think about lead magnets in general, how
they generate more money for you, and
kind of the different types of lead
magnets that you can You can reveal a
problem, you can do free trial, you can
do a onestep and a multi-step process.
Um, and so each ones of these are are
are different versions of this. So if I
if we were to look at this as our as our
as our little rubric here, right? Six
week challenge is going to be uh
essentially a three-step and a
multi-step process because most people
who work out for six weeks want to work
out more later, right? So it's like,
okay, cool. You're going to need this
other thing later. Gym Launch Secrets.
This one was more about revealing a
problem. So, it shows all the things
that you need to do and then people are
like, "Oh my god, this is so
overwhelming. There's a lot of things I
need to do to fix my gym. It'd be nice
if I had help." And so, then they they
take the next natural step. With Allen,
same thing. Now, with this business, the
way that this model was kind of
structured was almost like a premium
where again, you solve a problem for
someone, you help them grow their
agency, and then they're going to need
the software even more. And the way the
software was structured, it build um
Prestige Labs. So with with uh with this
the basically the problem that they had
is they didn't have a supplement sales
system. Once they implemented the
supplement sales system the next problem
they would naturally have is what
supplements do I sell which duh we have
prestige labs right and so in each of
these cases you want to think about can
I reveal a problem for my prospect can I
give them a trial of the thing I have or
is it one step in a multi-step process
and I give examples of these and then
you can have different delivery
mechanisms which I won't get into but
you can check that out there. So, the
third way to 10x your income is through
making customers worth more, which is
going to come down to in the fastest way
possible, pricing. And so, I talk about
price a ton. And it's because it's the
most powerful lever on profit. And if
you're in the game to make more money,
then you should try and raise it. And
so, the nice thing with this is that you
can do this again, whether you're an
employee or you're a solarreneur or
you're at a, you know, super big
business, it works the same way. Um, so
you got your pricing lever. Okay. So, as
an employee, you basically have three
options. All right. So, number one is
you can simply ask for more money. Now,
I don't recommend doing that because
you're not going to 10x your income that
way. So, then it's like, okay, so if I
just ask for more, ask. Okay, I might
get a little bit of a raise if I'm good.
If I'm not, they might just say no. The
way to really ask for it is to take on
more risk. And so you will be
compensated for the amount of value you
create, your ability to negotiate, how
replaceable that skill is, and most
importantly, the risk you're willing to
take on. And so a business owner gets
paid more than the employees in the
business because the business owner
takes on more risk. Right? Eduardo
Savin, who was the first investor in
Facebook, he put $30,000 up and that was
worth a gazillion dollars today. and he
really didn't do much besides providing
the first $30,000 of capital for the
servers for Facebook to begin. And so he
took on risk and as a result of that,
despite not really doing any work, he
was able to make a significant amount of
money. Now, as an employee, what does
taking on risk look like? It means that
you switch to a percentage of your
compensation or the entirety of your
compensation based on some key metric
that you have responsibility over that
you can draw a connection between what
you do and how much revenue or profit
the company makes. Now, in some
positions, like sales, it's a little bit
easier to draw that. And that's
typically how those roles are
structured. But if you know your job
well, then you can think of ways to tie
what you do to what the company makes.
And you should do that because the
closer you can tie yourself to revenue,
the more valuable you will be. The third
thing you can do as an employee is you
can just switch, right? You can start
applying to other roles uh either within
the business or in other businesses. And
I actually think that the within
business swap is one of the most
underrated. So like in terms of which
one of these will make you the most
money. This will probably make you the
most which is you taking on risk. You
switching sometimes you can get a
significantly larger raise than simply
asking. And I think the reason for that
is that if you have if you're in a role
where there's multiple people in your
role it sets a precedent for the
business that even if you're a higher
performer that they feel like they have
to then increase everyone else's pay
which is kind of a risk to the business.
Basically here you ask the business to
take on more risk versus here you take
on more of that risk. Now the switch
allows the business to maintain face and
allow you to get into a role that takes
on more responsibility or has a
different title and then you can earn
according to that. Now the final thing
here is obviously you can start a
business which then would switch your
category overall. But let's talk about
that. So the pricing lever here is
really related to your income. The
pricing lever here in businesses is
related to what you sell. Now I want to
be really clear here. An employee sells
your services. You just sell them on a
recurring contract. But fundamentally
it's what it is. And so I think people
see these in very different categories.
I don't see them as that different uh
personally. Obviously the only real
difference is risk. Now from a business
perspect because think about like this.
What's the difference in an employee in
1099? Mostly government but the
actual day-to-day obviously there's
control and you know have to show up on
time and you can have other you know
other other customers but the actual
like what you do doesn't phenomenally
change between being an employee and
being a 109 but a 1099 is a business
owner and an employee isn't. And so I
just think that if I can if I can smooth
over that wall, I think a lot more
people would be willing to take the risk
because fundamentally like the doingness
is not that dissimilar. And so here you
have services which you sell your time
for and you have a price which is your
salary or or the way that you negotiate
your compensation and that's it. Now as
a business owner you do the exact same
thing. But instead of having one boss,
you have many bosses and you have to
talk to them every day which are going
to be your customers. And so um I have
talked at this at length and still no
none of you do it. So the big thing to
do here is implement a price anchor. Now
a price anchor is basically just a price
that you put way above your normal
prices that mentally anchors how people
perceive the remainder of your menu. And
so people actually frame all numbers
with respect to the numbers they heard
first. And so by the way, if you're ever
selling something, you want to include
even earlier in the presentation massive
numbers. Even if it has nothing to do
with the price that you mentioned later,
just big numbers will will frame
people's minds in big big thoughts. So
that when you say uh and I'll give you
I'll give you a simple example and then
I'll tell you a story. So if I said
$10,000, right, and then I said $100, it
sounds very different than me saying
$100,
$10,000, right? It's a it's a different
shift in terms of oh my god, that's so
many different units. Right? Now,
obviously, you heard the first one
first, and that does influence it, but
big picture, the anchor makes everything
else seem cheap by comparison. And so,
let me tell you the story about a crazy
steakhouse that SB made. There's this uh
restaurant uh by Salt Bay, who's like a
meme, but he actually has like, I think,
like 10 or 11 locations, something like
that, called Nerret. And so, Nerret is a
a super expensive steakhouse. And
everything they have is a little bit
more than the very expensive steakouses.
So, like a normal steak there is, I want
to say like 90 bucks, which is pretty
steep, at least today. Uh, even for a
high-end steak place, maybe a hundred.
All right, but here's the thing is that
they have this gold menu, which they
just wrap the meat in gold foil, and
they charge like $2,000 to $3,000 for
these steaks. And you're thinking, why
on earth would someone go and spend $2
or $3,000? Because they want someone to
know they spent $200 or $3,000. And so
that would be by its very different a
luxury item where the price of the thing
itself uh confers the value to the
product. Meaning the more expensive it
is the more desirable it is. And the key
to luxury products is that other people
know how expensive it is so that you get
status by proxy by being able to afford
the product. Now that's very different
than a premium product where the value
isn't in the fact that it's expensive.
The value is in the fact that it is
significantly more valuable in terms of
the result or experience that it
delivers. This is what we call in the
biz a
profit
maximizer. And so what a lot of
entrepreneurs especially don't
understand is that the thing you sell
most of isn't necessarily the thing you
make the most money on. All right? So
let me say that again. So if you look at
McDonald's for example, they sell
burgers. They don't make a lot of money
on burgers. If they only sold burgers,
they would go out of business. And so
even though it's the core product, it's
not the profit maximizer. They make
significantly more money on fries and
Coke because the margins on fries and
coke are way way better than meat and a
bun and fresh lettuce and tomatoes and
onions and all the other stuff. And so
the thing you sell the most amount of is
not always the thing you make the most
money on. And so you can absolutely
build like their business now McDonald's
corporate's business is real estate, but
the franchisee business is really the
the Coke, ice cream, and and and fries
business because that's where they make
the disproportionate amount of their
profit. And so this is why the giveaway
thing that I was mentioning earlier is
so important is that you can have this
very valuable thing that you give away
for free and then you maximize your
profit with this other thing that's
significantly more expensive that is
typically going to be a very more
handheld more done for you more heavy
service more concierge more white glove
version of whatever it is that you sell.
Now if you sell on the product side
typically it's going to have to be newer
designs different materials uh that will
make a better experience. So, a friend
of mine actually implemented this into
his uh online business, and he had this
he just created this super expensive 101
version of his thing that was 10 times
more expensive. So, his thing was $500 a
month. He charged $5,000 a month for
this. It was a business to consumer
business. And what the craziest thing
happened. He then had a ton of people
take this more valuable offer, which he
had zero intention of actually selling.
He just wanted to have more people buy
the next thing. But not only that, a
higher percentage of people bought his
previously most expensive package
because it looked like the much more
affordable, more reasonable middle
option. Because I want to overd deliver,
I'm also giving you a fourth bonus way
of 10xing your income. And so if
leverage is getting more for what we put
in, then we want to take maximal
advantage of the assets we already have.
And so a big part of doing that is
saying, okay, who do I already know? And
so you want to hit your list with the
combination of those three things. So
you're like, "Okay, I'm going to
arbitrage myself and basically sell
stuff for more than it cost me. I'm
going to live in places that cost me
less than what I need to spend so I can
be more aggressive and take on less
personal risk so I can take on more
business risk." Cool. Next thing you're
like, "Okay, I need to give something
amazingly valuable away." Got it. That
generates more leads. Then I'm going to
upsell people into a super expensive
thing. Got it. And so then finally the
question would be like okay well who am
I going to do this to and so this is
where you look at your cell phone you
look at your email list you look at your
when I say email list just literally the
contacts that are in your email not like
you've developed some email lists now if
you're a business obviously you should
have an email list and if you don't
shame on you all right so you've got
your cell phone you've got your email
list um on top of that you've got all
socials and then let them know about
this free thing that you have and then
create the ascension process that
naturally leads from the giveaway where
you solved a problem. Uh sorry, you
revealed a problem, you gave them a
trial of a solution or a one-part
solution to a multi-step solution so
that they then naturally want to buy
your next thing. And so our largest
portfolio company actually ran this
exact play. And in one email campaign,
all right, so literally just like a
three email uh blast, right, to the list
that they had, they drove everyone to a
webinar where they just said, "Hey,
here's this amazing offer and they were
able to make $2.3 million from this one
campaign." Now, obviously, this is a
business that has millions of emails on
the list, but I mean, I don't know what
your income is now, but three emails for
2.3 million ain't bad. And so if we
scaled this down on one/10enth, then it
would be $230,000. And if we did it 100x
less, then it'd be
$23,000. But this is a great way to
implement all of the stuff that I just
said immediately. Yeah. And the reason
that this is one of the strongest ways
of 10xing your income, there's no real
additional cost, right? And so you're
just making money for not a lot of cost
because we've already incurred the cost
of getting the customers. And so again,
arbitrage being a theme here, like we
already paid for this, so cost is zero,
and we're going to sell this thing that
cost a lot to them, but not much for us.
And if you like this video, you're going
to love this video on 10 ways to make a
million dollars.